hey guys welcome to the broken podcast
i'm pierre 2pi and with me cinnamon
toast can hello everybody glad to be
back glad you had me back again I feel
so special thank you so much
you're welcome even though you shaved
your beard how about that yeah my face
is naked like a babe we talked about
this blossom well I saw the last episode
and I'm like Jesus Christ no oh my god I
mean it cuz the beauty right you're like
woo my mmm you look again thank you baby
you should be proud I'm proud
oh and by the way we got the mr. Jack
septic we oh my gosh jacksepticeye's
amazing he's gonna come on can you
believe it - he's so Irish high-fives
round oh stop it a parting teal and yeah
we're gonna we're gonna start off this
episode because I feel like both you and
I can are experts at that damn memes oh
[Music]
yeah I mean we live on the internet
we've lived on the internet all of our
lives we were born on the internet you
know forged and born was the the bein me
McCain remember doesn't matter you can't
you obviously aren't a meme Pro if he's
don't even know you don't even know the
big mountain cycle down do they have
dates on them no all right we met we
made our own memes what we're trying to
say and okay yeah we made our own means
I told you to make three and you go went
ahead and made six of them well at first
you told me to make five Vince so you
know well if their names are hard and
then we made three instead I never I
would never say meme so hard okay okay
so whoever its memes becomes the most
shareable or viral viral meme a bowl
what's what's the cool way of expressing
it I don't know I'm sure when you guys
like the most I guess yeah which one
wins cuz there always has to be a winner
always Oh
do you want I feel like you you should
start because you haven't been more of
them okay well yeah we'll put up the
picture in the video but if you're
listening we'll try and describe as well
as you can weld of the first one that I
made I was actually like what would
actually be like a kind of a mean kind
of thing and so you take a look
we have spongebob here yeah he's looking
at beautiful it's like and the spongebob
episodes were like something really
crazy happens it's like a super gross
looking picture is like he's on drugs
it's like a crack core or a cracker
racist hey special kind of does look
like a cracker actually now that you
mention it but he quickly as a hashtag
that I cried for Jesus Christ I don't
know which ones worse really that's
offensive
hey okay it's just a hashtag no filter
meme I went with the old classics to
begin with you know death so you win
with a meme already to warm up my pal I
can't just you can't just make up a
brand-new amazing meme only like I've
been doing only had like a few hours me
why do you think I didn't write three of
them this is this is what all these
effort
Mary Mary wanted me to make this one and
so I did I made it hey I like it I like
it it's okay I feel like this one could
be viral super viral it gave this 3 out
of 10 viral points though yeah yeah it's
a good start we gotta warm up slowly so
show me show me yours I want to see
yours ok this meme is called the Diggy
mom Diggy mom Diggy mom instead of
Digimon and it's I trust a Digimon
that's [ __ ] mouth alright do you mind
that should be a meme Digimon
don't try to make me my memes ass
Digimon ok ok we saw a Digimon digital
monsters Digimon do it champion and
that's uh I forgot his name
I can't I Kondo man or something the
first Digimon can't believe us so his
name do you have like dick digital
watches over there yeah we have to get
up watches ok yeah you gotta follow me
that did they do that ninjas wear those
whether yogging even eat
sake man that's it can I can i okay okay
tell me event tell about your meme five
minutes creating this it's Stiggy mom
instead of Digimon it's a it looks like
the Dolan mean you know where it's a
poorly painted version of the Digimon
the active the dinosaur looking one yes
that Charmander which what was he called
I forget I don't know much German uh so
I have some great points about this
first of all it's built upon the 90s
love which which gives extra meme viral
points I feel like the only ninety kids
get the nineties right yeah even though
they're born in the 90s so they don't
actually remember much of the 90s but
anyway hey I was born in the eighties uh
Diggy mom writes in poor grammar which
is also mean points so Dolan in
spooderman and that doggy one and and
what's special about Diggy mom is he
makes shitty your mom jokes okay
your mama's teeth are so yellow she
spits butter oh yes they're yellow pink
Iman is Nicki mom so like I actually
made a template for people to make their
own memes yeah that was the point
see I didn't understand that you said
make me sounds like okay it's okay we
get some variation this way guys some
more is shitty Diggy mom's yo mama's so
greasy companies buy their oil from her
hey-oh Diggy mom tea and final one your
mama's so flat she's jealous of the wall
oh he's just digging money so your mama
to sunny day yeah he has poor grammar
and really bad jokes yeah I mean I feel
like old your mama it wasn't hard to
find bad something amazing
all right you want to share share me one
of yours yeah I'll go into my second one
the second one is a real hashtag
relatable oh yeah see I went try to
infer it
okay so whatever whenever we go out to
the store Mary she always wants like all
the candles she's like all these candles
by these candles so we fill up would get
like 10 different candles and when we
get home she lights all of them and lets
them burn all day long and so my meme
here it's a dirt where it says at the
top it's got like a bunch of candle that
says girlfriend wants $50 with the
candles there at the bottom it's got a
piece from one of Queen these music
videos video which one we've got all the
candles in the background these guys
hands out and Mary's faces on top of it
burns them all first day there you go
it's relatable minimum a she's got the
most amazing ladies I like the picture
yeah but always always wonder like what
what you just you can't actually smells
each candle I like this one like this
like this one and we get home and she
lights them all I'm like how you came
and smell it it's just like a melting
pot of candle smell and I mean how in
the day they're all gone you don't know
how blessed you are
oh yeah cuz my sir buys all the candles
to like this is a common girl from
problem I don't know what it is candles
they just keeps buying candles mhm
I can't explain it but chief just leaves
them around we have literally candles in
every locker that we open here in our in
our flag just a candle sitting there
yeah they're just candles everywhere so
she does she doesn't even burn him she
just workhorse candles yeah wow I don't
know which ones worse
which one is worse can we just all agree
on that candles are awful they should
not exist just Kansas it's 2000 2015
let's get with times all right yeah very
I got really upset here you shouldn't
get a mad about it yes that's been my
life alright okay see I would share this
meme because I can relate to it good job
good job slinging a really relatable one
hashtag relatable oh man alright what's
your wish your wish you're next meme so
I try to think about you know there's a
lot of celebrities that are memes
we got mecard geerdon Freeman Keanu
Reeves Nicolas Cage yeah and they're all
kind of like sub actors maybe not going
Gordon said Gordon Freeman is edit named
Morgan Freeman the Astra sorry I think
my whole garden is like a yeah yeah
there's a habit live happen I do we can
pray and I see a meme I see what I did
there he did it so I was thinking I was
thinking about brandon fraiser do you
know who that is
yeah this fur guy that's in the mummy
video jammies he's the mummy guy and the
jungle George yeah yeah why is he not a
mean he fits the perfect formula oh Mema
fication yeah he's used to be really
famous so everyone knows about him he
has the weirdest [ __ ] face and he
plays in a bunch of weird movies if you
search brandon fraiser which I bet you
are already right now every picture is
me mobile hmm every picture what what
would the theme of his mean be there see
see it needs a little bit of working ah
so you got you got the basics down and
now I need to leave it to the peoples um
and I try to combine it yeah yeah yeah
no that's what do we do
that's perfect I'll throw it belongs to
the the people of the internet now just
do what you won't need with it um I'd
tried one I try to do that gotcha gotcha
song now you're just somebody that I
used to know so I was gonna do now I'm
just somebody that you used to know like
some text before and then yeah okay I
tried all right then that's that's all I
got I'm sorry oh I feel like I raised a
good point with brandon fraiser I
brought him up he's there he's there now
he will be a meme I can have him all
right know why I got so defensive that's
it
do you just making yourself mad over
there
Oh [ __ ] kennels I'm still rile up
about it
Oh candles ah so my next meme I took an
already existing meme which is 60
spider-man and he's sitting there with
all the pictures around him it's just
like a boss so a toy yeah it is I took
the other meme sanic yeah and I placed
him
in the place of spider-man's oh you did
that's a Sanok sitting there there's the
one I spent a lot of time on exactly I'm
like yeah that's pretty prison got a
Photoshop all this make a lot of
Photoshop so it's sanic setting the
shitty sanic fan art I mean beautiful
Seneca yeah beautiful and he says like a
boss yes Cassie he speaks in the Doland
crappy spooderman stuff Jane I don't
know that about something that's good
well I see let's both of him some of
them do some of them don't I don't think
you might really knows senex still being
developed all people really know he's
gonna go fast but that is what is
underdeveloped that's for sure yeah just
a few more years and can be looking at
it okay I'll get there one day I like
that one man should you go since you
have more I still like yours should you
go through all of your research and then
I can get out like somebody there's all
those would be pretty quick there just
kind of YouTube relatable more than
anything you do that then show me more
all right the next one is uh I was named
bad luck Brian Oh bad luck Brian yeah
badly Browns the next one and it's uh I
just thought of it when I was thinking
about comments and people want you to
play these certain games or just a good
game on YouTube so bad luck Brian it
says plays a good game no one watches
its mechanics it makes me cry every team
that's very relatable to youtubers like
no one else will this would never go
viral because it's not related yeah no
one knows what I'm talking about but
yeah it's a real thing with YouTube
sides like please play this amazing
awesome game yeah yes finally I can play
this good game and you do and no one
watches it a taste of your viewership
watches it it's so painful when that
happens like it really hurts yeah lately
did it but I wanted to play this one is
actually a very big thing I'll see the
next one just breaks your heart oh my
god I forget what this guy's name is the
douche bags bag yeah the douche bag one
yeah you should bet the douche bag
hat-wearing guy
it's another youtube label thing and
thus whenever there's like a scumbag
Steve that's it's gonna bag Steve
whenever better yet whenever someone
famous does you can go look on YouTube
that's what this says here says someone
famous does there's his face at the
bottom makes a YouTube video crying
about it
and hey as fans there may be a lot of
people going oh oh but if they think of
your YouTube you make videos for a
living someone does it's trending
everyone's like oh I'm so sad and you
just pull your camera out you're like oh
oh yeah yeah it's it's so there's no
good excuse to make a video where you're
just gonna cry I'm looking at your at
your last meme here okay don't don't
don't splice I need to explain the
thought process there was a lot o talk
process it is me so I realized that
memes are just reaction phases to things
like trollface megusta um Mitch please
why you know it's like a reaction to
something
yeah right so I try to think of okay
what what what is a reaction common
phrase that I can make a me matter I
tried to think about that a lot and I
thought okay which please oh yeah that's
a mean say what that that was also
apparently I mean I don't [ __ ] know
why I tried I'm okay with this meme
taken uh I've inserted a mouse that's a
[ __ ] meme too I can't believe my eyes
it's a [ __ ] meme okay okay so sighing
so beautiful it's [ __ ] meme so
everything's enjoy I even tried okay I
tried okay I'm I like that another Z
it's so simple it's a meme uh so I just
kind of gave up okay so I was thinking I
this is was my current mood like I just
couldn't handle it so I present to you
too many Chin's mean me just giving up
you just like throwing your hand up so
that this picture it's it's it's a white
background the drawing in paint classic
screen Liao and but it looks it looks
like a flaccid penis with a little nuts
on each side in a face just like kind of
like all right straight up it's just
man it's too many Chin's man it's not
applies it being the first thing I
thought when I looked at this was this
should be a I can't FET to this reaction
meme ah dude yes yes it's like I can't
FAP to this and here's this flaccid
wrinkly P is this little nuts going like
what I was looking for all along
I drew this perfect piece of art and I
didn't know what caption to fit with it
there you go
that's sync you can you fulfilled my
wildest meme fantasies thank you so much
it can also be just seen as like a just
I don't know like a nerdy dude or
something I can see that I can see the
hands now that you told me what it's
about um but it looks it looks it looks
that's that's available lets you see
what you want to see my ring and I saw
penis yeah alright that was that was our
memes let us know what you think about
him if you have any memes feel free to
post them in high Stag broken podcasts
yeah you guys should make some broken
podcast memes and see what you guys come
up with it's okay to just poop all over
Felix he can handle it I'm Aramis can we
have some beautiful comments from our
beautiful listeners
[Music]
awesome I never seen their faces but I
assume they're beautiful I can see their
pictures and they look beautiful like
this looks like a panda or a cow I'm not
too sure
beautiful beautiful right well I'm glad
to hear your independence and we visit
everybody okay I am absolutely Alex King
says hey bro you look really tired I
think you should rest more hours come on
videos can wait oh I so worried about
homes I am tired
alright we found these so late because
you're an [ __ ] to me oh you have to
mean how do you feel Ken how dare being
a different time zone yeah how dare you
I don't know I'm not telling now but I
remember the other episodes I've been
really [ __ ] tired but it's good it
makes me all giggly like a little baby
hmm a little baby oh we got Alex glint
here Gillette galette grill it all it
isn't really the best the man can get
like Gillette arrangement yeah Kim
southern voice when he was giving Felix
tips on how to speak more southern had
me in a melted pool Wow oh come on
someone has there you have one fan can
this achievement got disel so what the
[ __ ] is so special about your accent I
mean it's southern it's cool I don't
like a lot of people that embarrassed of
their southern accents I embrace it I
make it mine I own it
hey y'all obviously it's working for you
I mean either either she's in a melted
pool of like oh are all right melted her
face southern face the energon space no
no actually commented in it so that's
kind of weird
those are demonstra last tweet her dying
tweet as her face belted
speaking of dying tweet georgia girl 93
says I'm glad I spent the last hour my
life watching this rest in peace joke
that's great to have you on as a fan
another great man we got here Mercedes
Frick's Mercedes what
name OSHA's new metric cars anyway huh
this is Hugh
this is pewds that accent was gorgeous
yeah except not really what and it's got
212 likes what isn't what uh what is my
accent never work for myself and you're
I'm Eric did you what's wrong with my
accent not he listened to it say say say
ninja and yet ah mmm
sorry it makes me laugh every time you
had it and it my accent can be beautiful
too can it give me a give me your best
beautiful Swedish accent like speaks big
some Swedish to me and like make me make
me melt haha hi hi Eric in there how
what are you doing
no I don't even know speak speak actual
Swedish and just say this say something
to me that's beautiful makes me melt can
do hard it lifts it in 20 - Lea I mean I
would stick out but it mean Langley
mmm-hmm
Salaria then me freaked out with that no
idea you said but I could only imagine
it's like the most terrible thing I you
should know we we practice Swedish come
on man hello I know that we just the you
said yes a lot remember that no no I
didn't say uh white a peacock great name
uh says you are an [ __ ]
Wow so it's either you or me that's
somebody knows maybe the one associated
with this is an [ __ ]
maybe we're just one big jump but this
like you well I'll be left but she left
cheek on the cheek
yep the shark is always better so let's
get my moves uh see I think never do you
should do more RCX models UK says can
was translating you can sometimes hear
the keys yeah yeah what's up with that
Ken I was transected here you're
cheating hmm can you cheating you can
hear me cheating they can hear you from
what was I looking up Swedish words you
yeah you google again see I'm typing
right now can you get can you hear it
yeah did you hear that that's yeah I
heard that
it'll be type of really hard looking up
Swedish words yet see maybe you were
typing Noren maybe I felt like flinch
the keys as hard as I can I'm
professional you can't hear me clicking
I got compressors I got engaged on this
thing shoot you can't even hear my air
conditioner on right now don't even tell
me can hear my keys cuz I don't need to
cheat to know Swedish okay well you lost
anyways they're just mad 106 likes
whatever you guys are just guys just
taking Felix Assad because I owned him
with my southern as' whatever makes you
happy can we have jacksepticeye coming
on he's gonna help us with some few
things this day to stay toasty my bro
skis hey we're back with Jax Jax empty
is it really yeah could it be could it
be that one and only Jax if decoy wow
I'm so honored as a flag on
jacksepticeye our only our only fan of
the show tell Andi I'm that one viewer
you guys have yeah yeah it's always
funny when you mentioned stuff like yeah
yeah heard that on the podcast I'm like
hey what has has into her anyway as we
come back to the podcast yet is Jack our
first reoccurring guest uh yes hey
congratulations you are yours
reoccurring yes yeah anything else no no
you couldn't find anybody else you're
the first person we asked what are you
talking about yeah we're a we inhabit
anybody else like we have no more guest
to ever have you've known in France no
one else wants to be in this [ __ ] yeah
everybody else hates you by now oh sorry
I love you guys you go you guys are my
friends
ah that's right just don't get me sick
over Skype if you're doing it yeah so
yeah speaking you got to mention yeah I
went to Japan after you swore you'd
never go back cuz you get sick thank you
for mentioning that yeah yeah that's
exactly what happened I got so sick last
time I didn't I
and I never been that sick before I was
laying in the [ __ ] new yoke and
hoping I wouldn't die and then I'm like
I'll never return this cursed land I
swear my grandparents grave I will never
return
the last time was your South Park thing
as well wasn't it yeah I don't think oh
god yeah that was a bad trip yeah
so is it like the say you stick with the
same thing or so I just got a cold oh
are you getting down with the sickness
what look oh no but am i I became like a
germaphobe when I was there I Lily like
don't touch me my girlfriend if my same
way near me yeah just you know did you
have like the pocket hand sanitizer
eating like rub it all over yeah yeah
it's really her own baby ice cream my
whole body with it but I heard she got
sick yeah she got sick now after me
actually she's she's uh upstairs sick so
it was the opposite of last time and she
she's yeah exactly she made me sick last
time and she got really angry now at me
she's like you make you DeeDee Jimmy you
know why you did it last time
nothing come on that's part of Fame in
relationship you had to make each other
sick that's the only way it's the only
way you don't share your germs you don't
love them hey enough about me and my
sickness Jack how are you have you been
I'm great I'm always happy I haven't
been sick in over a year
I'm fantastic see that's great I was
gonna say something me say it I was
gonna say it to myself first I was just
gonna say like I never leave my gaming
cage and that's why I never get sick and
then assume it I get someone at somebody
membership mail like here's your mail
for the day and you're like oh but I put
it through the letter contamination it's
like right where we sit at home with
YouTube so much
I do yeah yeah we become bubble voice
and as soon as we we leave our bubble I
expected to get sick when I went to
Boston yeah came back I was like I'm not
sick we're good did it get that that
looks right
apocalypse PAX pox or whatever they call
it how was my accent and get today I'm
gonna tell it to action he'll tell us
all about your trip I know putting out
when you ask questions like this uh it
was awesome um I didn't expect like that
many people there and it's my first
convention ever my first time ever in
America I think this is this is awesome
cuz these are my people it was the first
time in America even yeah my first time
doing like lots of things how did I
smell different yeah it smells gross it
smell it smells fatter mm could you
Casilla the the fat bubbling I could
smell the cheese the spreadable cheese
everywhere the plastic fake cheese I was
like I could smell the forced positivity
out of everyone the Fords positivity yes
they have a nice day like oh yeah yeah
they have to say bad don't you tell me
how to live my life America that's so
that's how I raised to be a fresh
eternal day and you're just like no go
away from me no it was cool I liked it
what's our first time meeting like other
youtubers properly like a group of other
youtubers and spending time with to him
so that was cool
yeah that's cool yeah did you did you
fanboy over anyone you met I found Boyd
over American jontron the most oh yeah
it's like I know everyone else he met is
gonna be offended its sorry this was a
lot of other people there okay yeah
they're both cool people like Mark was
the main reason I ever like went there I
wanted to go meet him and then I didn't
know John dramas gonna be there was like
oh my god his shot Ron yeah right there
I want to touch his face Yongchun was a
lot nicer and then I thought it would be
that's kind of got not too bad but he's
just super nice like that that's every
is he's whenever you meet other
youtubers you always expect them like
the one I'll never talk to the for it to
be like kind of mean I don't know why
yeah like I don't know you everyone
expects Felix to be mean everyone expect
me to be an [ __ ] so they know like
I'm just a normal person and they're so
like wow wow you didn't tell me to screw
off you Thanks it's great everyone just
thinks the lowers of you ever yeah which
is probably a good thing super low
expectations yeah
exceed them me I don't have to make any
effort in
eating anyone ever is great and I met
smooth mcgroove as well and he's just
stupidly nice he's that a cappella dude
right yeah like yeah he's already super
super nice it's almost like he's new
nice you're almost got taken back cuz he
likes so nice like are you uh yeah real
it was him his wife and jontron we went
out with them I'm Shane from digital
gaming wait I didn't know like I knew
his channel oh yeah him yeah cuz he's
never on camera I think I thought
everyone shared that channel is there
somebody dependable on that channel well
he's British as well which I didn't know
okay um but I met smooth and it was just
like he's like really enthusiastic
talking to music oh yeah that's cool man
I was like yeah I like hey go ahead of
myself okay man besties forever I find
that whenever I'm with people who are
too nice I just kind of take advantage
of that and I become too mean is it like
it's like when you see like a super cute
animal you just want to pet it but y'all
just was squeezy
oh love you so much that's a fair point
that's probably what it is it just
sounds a good add no I don't know it's
just cuz I try to make jokes that makes
fun of them and they are just so nice
that they don't laugh at it they just
like haha
I'm so paranoid about that when I meet
ok I I come off super abrasive when
people beat me first so loud
and I swear a lot and I'm so worried
people are gonna hate me
yeah I know what you mean you think that
they're gonna offend it cuz you don't
know if they are like get the joke or
not yeah yeah I get that around nice
people sometimes it's okay though when
you're in America they won't hate you to
your face you'll never know hey I'd
rather have them hate to my face man
yeah it is done then they'll all go this
way so would you do kin that Jackson -
yeah that's what I do whenever I get out
of these calls you guys like go and call
some other people like oh my god I just
helped you and it'd be game then Jen Ken
plays those games where you like punch
youtubers like you remember that time
Jack ha ha ha
screw jack
jump jack you want to be doing YouTube a
year screaming Jack I didn't know house
is that is that the American Way you
make a video about it you get your
passive-aggressive view yeah was it
called be like you're like you make
snide tweets at people who yeah so so
tweeting people you don't even like you
don't even include them in the daily
maybe we won't see it yeah we all know
them you're feeling that yeah I like I
like poking fun at people it's fun
oh we know but I I like I hope that I
come off as someone that can take it all
so I always worry I'll be that guy that
but it's like can't take it you know our
scene is that like oh yeah huh you're
stupid no kid you're stupid how dare you
[Laughter]
no one ever really made fun of you made
fun of me has anyone ever like made an
effort to [ __ ] on you I don't know they
probably have but it doesn't really get
to me yeah right yeah you don't
associate yourself with those people
anyway yeah it's like kooky I'm sure I'm
sure plenty of people have made fun of
all three of us oh yeah I make fun of
myself more than I think you'll make fun
of me yeah exactly I one makes fun of me
cause I wanted nothing to make fun
I'm very self-aware about my flaws if
people say I'm loud and annoying I'm
like yeah yeah my channel yep you got me
there to tell you yeah thanks for
telling me
hmm appreciate it it's like I guess like
the only one really cuz I can you're
really hairy and I'm like thanks for the
update I had no idea I know you don't
know hot it wasn't here cuz of all my
hair right
I had this just grew yesterday you know
it's crazy people comment about my chin
and I'm just like yeah I know it's big
haha you you think about your mole as
well which is really like unfair oh yeah
because sometimes I shave and people
like ways you watch it I come from ready
for whatever what is that that was
really shocked ilat before this oh man
what everything said when I had the
beard and I never come back to LA we got
make a video about that get a stick and
poke it sick because that's really a
thing that never ever bothered me in my
life until yeah the internet pointed out
that I have a mole then it's like okay
it's [ __ ] mole what do you want I I
just say my gray hairs people the people
make fun of my gray hair I had the
little tiny streaks going through it
like they up what what oh sorry I had
the option to it take it away but I said
no because I I embrace my flaws I don't
need you ain't nobody telling me how to
be beautiful all right whenever whenever
you grow your mustache out just like
your mole grow those crazy witch hair
that uh it does I gotta trim it pretty
often yet it's not that bad it just it's
you sticks out so you should just let it
grow and like have one big braid can
your mom yeah - that's amazing
I'm gonna do that yeah yeah it may take
years but bring it between no hair and
all the hair sounds like a good idea but
the in-between parent is gonna be
horrible it's so awkward when people cuz
I mean I guess I shouldn't talk but yeah
I remember I had a friend growing up
where they had a super huge mole on his
forehead and he had like even hair
growing out of it and it oh yeah I could
not talk to him without staring at it
impossible I wonder if people feel that
about me but I felt like - is beauty
they are just mesmerized by the beauty
if I see people stare I'm like yep they
look they're looking at your beautiful
live they're enjoying it I do that
anyway I look at people's mouths when
they talk because I hate looking people
in the eyes when they're talking to me
there's a making point like yeah yeah
some people are really awkward about
that yeah
like some people stare at your eyes and
then they like look around but some
people just stare only at your eyes for
the entire hear water station yeah
you can't do that either it's kind of
like when people do that in videos
because they try to be more professional
like the oh yes they're in the camera
but no one talks to you that way anyway
so it's kind of weird it's only the
worst when you can tell they're like
making an effort to stay a nob yeah a
little bigger and they're like yeah
stare into your soul yes uh alright look
away and talk to him I have a trick for
that you should stare at the forehead it
feels better for it yeah stare stare at
the bridge of their nose right between
the eyes
do you imagine them naked same time I do
that anyway
talk to everybody
Jack I feel like we're all experienced
people here we're experienced in life
well where's this going
are you ready to answer some some
comments some questions about life Oh
go throw me down to clown right now down
to clown
[Music]
okay
what is our was our first question you
want me to read it for you
yes filmmaking it's from Casimir's oh of
course that person um how does one
seduce Sean Bean personal reasons
he says hmm our she actually you offer
Sean being a role where he does not die
yeah I was gonna say that
the Sean Bean is that the guy from guys
did everything any movies Lord of the
Rings um all the movies where he dies in
pretty much he he doesn't everything has
he ever been in a movie where he doesn't
die I don't think so like he even the
sufferer he's not the villain he's still
done is like a craziest like the most
memorable characters in movies usually
da and he's like he's that guy he was
fishing for saying that America but he
doesn't really like dying any epic wait
though it's more like yeah you're gonna
die sorry should I was always sad
because my a satellite in the cold night
oh thanks for spoiling that movie
I forgot I it's not a billion years old
or anything
you totally I didn't even know he was in
that way he didn't die in an epic way
crushed by satellite you got me you got
this epic death everything that's yeah
that's pretty as a pretty aunt pretty
easy answer just yeah he's also the
mimin and simple that one does not one
does not slide into more yeah yeah
people have made memes about me and he's
also very publicly affectionate to one
my godson watch Jackson vol know how to
steal Sean Bean from you just something
really dramatic like gosh except I have
a wiki how how do a wiki how it is so
this is not actually week II how I find
this honor like the darkest corner of
the internet how to steal someone's man
oh okay can I go ahead and and get get
it over with because I don't have any
other [ __ ] ricky ass and I'm just done
with it just get it out your system go
ahead they got some pretty good points
here so it says how to steal still man
the classy way
step one don't dress like a hooker
around him that's a mistake instead
cover yourself up
but then when oh I love this but then
when she's not looking
and the wife rip off your top and reveal
a little skin it will intrigue him and
make him think you rip all have you
magical powers
so basically have like terrible clothes
no terrible yeah that you can just rip
yeah this is what his wife looks way
just put your boobs out yeah shaking him
yeah look at me really yeah I'm still in
your man stealing your main a security I
think you're still more than hit her man
dude you may listen man in the Miss
energy you get a man hey if you're
reading a [ __ ] wiki how about if
we're already like you've already lost
the battle except we're doing it right
now where we're helping a customer so
don't worry cuz I'm here don't feel bad
about this uh step to create a fake
Twitter account and start sending him
sexy private messages so fake one where
you offer you have to give to follow you
bet some messages yeah yeah but level
look the easy for you just poops poops
in the thumbnail sometimes my boobs are
out it's easy after Tiffany sending
private messages about wild fantasies
and sex talk this one make him think of
you oh really
but it will start making him question
whether his girlfriend or wife is really
that exciting
don't you wish your girlfriend was hot
like me they will also make him call the
police
Twitter police would you do that Jack
get out of here scout scour his Facebook
page for oh I love this one scour his
page for little details check his
Facebook page and find out little things
about him his mother's maiden name his
nephews birthday ah those ones that
everyone knows right I'm one of these
relationship memes always art me Wiki
house always go straight for being the
creepiest stalker you can possibly be
yeah you're still a man stalking
well the best part about this is the own
him but all you're learning
learning's into a spreadsheet I'd
spokesman the spread referent that is
easily searchable by time and date and
keyword so that next time you it says in
those exclamation and whatever run into
him coincidentally you can strike up a
conversation that is pretty easy using
the spreadsheet I mean if you get your
spreadsheet on your phone right there
like oh and your mom's birthday
yesterday oh yeah your nephew's name is
Jerry am i right don't all dogs fight
Nolensville
surgery your boobs out and shake them
you forget if that fails just tear up
your clothes a great relationship advice
ten out of ten there's two more points
and it's to start dating a guy that you
don't like and then step to the final
step get into a fight with this guy and
then invite the Hutus Sean Bean over and
then just tell him that you really just
don't want to be alone do your hair and
your makeup perfectly and and they use
some eyedrops to make it look like you
were crying when he comes over
hug him tightly and tell him that you
make him feel so much better
but sure that's going to get you what
you think it's gonna take Lyceus way to
do it that's classy that's classy that
you're welcome cuz I'm worse Sean be
little lip startin to get your boobs out
so I can learn more about the memes and
everything straight to prison you
getting sick of my weaker house I need
to stop this is getting weird I'll never
stop though but you can't can't stop
won't stop
it wasn't even Vicki how so [ __ ]
alright well I'm sorry no wait that I
wrote that article by the way um he paid
that up yourself tell me your amazing
ideas then yeah in here hey we already
here we got it we're done we did it yeah
that person has helped oh yeah that
classy it's stalker good crazy person
ever good point oh I'll let you pick the
next one then alright the next question
comes from Sydney when gaming for
yourself what is your go-to snack
order out or do you enjoy making
something in your own kitchen
hmm but is this a real Christian I
wasn't ready
yeah yeah that's the question what's
your favorite snack could you go do you
go for like some Bagel Bites Doritos
Pizza Mountain Dew MLG I don't eat when
I gain what it's like III barely knows
is that bad I mean well for the fur the
first thing with this is like when you
gain for yourself
yeah oh what's that
ha ha ha ha ha no silly people he's a
condescending Ken
don't be so Ken descending yeah
hello memes you may another one oh my
god get kinder Cindy and Candice Candice
indeed some no I order out way too much
it's like dominoes every second day me
too I'm it's like I blame YouTube for
making me fat no it's me
it's my flannel you so long I don't know
Dominus though but yeah my sales gets
pissed that I orgy bougie oh I don't I
don't have time to cook man what am I
supposed to do too busy no order I don't
order out that much yeah I get my go-to
snack is I figured the call the summer
sausages you guys I'm talking about no
these are those little sausages a little
salt actually pretty big those oh we
call them genies call Roy okay well I
cut them up and I put cheese on a little
Smokies yeah a little smoky I don't know
that really small either way I guess
chop those up and I put some cheese on
them and put them to microwave that
smile that's my go-to oh my god that's
so American
I can't nothing awesome cheese on it
yeah microwave negatively with some
cream cheese on it too I mean have guys
making fun of me time I ordered Domino's
all time shut up hey I don't know what
it is all time that's some Jack yeah
yeah oh yeah I got like some some some
habanero cheese at the one that's a
little spicy do you guys know how to
cook at all yeah good what about me or
whatever what like if you actually try
to cook could you cook a table
oh yeah I'm a great cook I used to cook
for my family when I lived at home like
every single day oh do you know how to
cook we using some
oh yeah I don't have time to cook yeah
like YouTube is like 24/7 yeah I mean if
I'm not you know making videos I'm just
sitting here staring at my computer not
doing anything but I'm not gonna go cook
mmm time ain't got time for that ain't
get inget ampere day I like good food
but I don't like the time it takes to
cook it yeah waiting on these days sorry
I just cook eggs and bacon in the
morning for myself that's it like a true
American burger it's like your national
dish isn't it oh gee you guys have a
question
jeez have cooking class in school like
whole Mac I don't know it wasn't offered
with my school okay but they do it was
it was an option for us but like it was
the it was the girl subjects day when
cookie even though I went to school I
was like I like food I wanna cook a but
it's like people would've made did you
pick it no I did like you you pick like
the first three years and then the
second three years you get to pick again
him so yes it's four years yeah so the
second three years I picked it and I was
absolutely awesome at it well it was
then that was totally my favorite class
yeah it's funny I love cooking cuz there
cuz we did it kind of young though we
were like in fourth grade or something
or fifth grade maybe no sixth grade
no actually seventh grade bugs out of
your mind uh well the thing was that we
never it was so easy to [ __ ] up because
we all sucked and I remember the only
thing we spend time doing was to make
sure that if someone else [ __ ] up we
made sure that the teacher found out
about it oh what a douche even if
someone like burn their pie just a
little bit it's me and my friend would
always be like oh Jesus Christ
HM oh it burns my ice teaching odd I
drew this oh my god um that was good
times so yeah that's why I don't cook I
like to cook for friends open know ya
know so cook if you guys come over here
I'll treat you some some of my famous
Swedish lasagna lady some meatball don't
know meatballs yeah I can do the
meatball
one okay oh that's not little hey was
those the next question um Jack do you
have anyone do I have question I think
you should read it yet give me the
questions I think I did yeah yes oh this
is not long water
go ahead Jack we believe in you hi pewds
and ken i feel mostly ken will relate to
this as he is a toast himself by a host
imma toasty toast so recently I've been
really enjoying toast as an admirable
I guess hey my mom told me that I eat
too much toast I will become a toast
this really concerns me and I think I
can feel the transformation happening
last night I had a dream that I was
eating toast the toast I was eating
called me a can of oh I do not want to
be accountable how can I maintain my
love of toast without becoming a monster
that eats its own kind
that's a release paradox Linda Wow
that's from Lucy Marta can yeah Lucy
Ellen wait wait what is it biggest
concern here that he's a cannibal or
that he's a tough but this is gonna come
toast or she huh it's loose again and go
go Ken you're the most toast jelly I'm
gonna hear Tom again pretty toasty I
mean in cannibalism is never the answer
no matter how hungry you are so but it's
toast it's awesome no you can't really
stop eating the toast a sub something so
torn I mean oh God if the first thing
you have to do is play the game I am
bread no that was no Trevor no no don't
don't play that don't plug that game
that would give you the best feel of
what it's gonna be like to be a toast
because you're not going to stop eating
toast
you just can't good point you guys play
that game you know see you see how it
feels
and if you can handle that what if I
don't want to go out of nine but what if
you should put really disgusting things
on her toast
just like hate the toast do ya it
depends on what's on your toast if you
have like Jam you're gonna stick to
everything nobody wants dad I love Jam
on my toes
okay tongue yeah if you're a jammy toast
though you're gonna get stuck to
everything
oh if you're American you better put
cheese on that toast America well yeah
why you should breathe in woohoo did did
we answer the question no no I didn't I
mean yous gonna have to just got to live
with it you're just gonna have to eat
other toast it's the only way yeah I
can't stop there's no you have no option
that me whenever you basically like to
shake a monster you get like this can
decisions on their own kind
I'm sorry lost between you guys what the
[ __ ] it has happened I'm sorry can't go
whoa
so there's something like you guys did
not didn't notice um you know I'm
obviously a little hmm more analytic and
I know this stuff between the lines and
you don't okay goes past a normal mind
say it I got a comment saying how bout
pissy was because I had keep talking so
highly about just hit me um anyway uh he
said she says she's toast and that must
mean she is said it toasted which means
she's high from smoking marijuana so it
makes sense for her mom to be upset
about it that's baked not toasted no
toasted works to break stuff let me just
say that dude I'm so toasted right now
no one ever says that well it's there
maybe she's whenever got like a really
good tan this holistic yeah yeah that
makes sense too yeah maybe she did both
right right here's what you need to do
Lizzie um don't smoke when your mom is
around and don't and don't toast in this
guy now wait ones don't smoke and toast
don't smoke a toast baby they go there
we go ha she sang some smoke too much
toast you
come comatose Oh witty Unni how did we
stop this oh my god question Nick well I
had some stuff about Germans but I guess
you can save that it's my job in yeah
yeah yeah sup guy i'm ray william
johnson raywj a oh my gosh Bailey Rae
Johnson is here we have another famous
youtuber listening to this podcast Wow
here's my question I'm in a
long-distance relationship with this
amazing girl but we can't see each other
to do the prize of airfare that is that
what it is what yes what would you
suggest doing please help sent by a
skater 0 7 7 7
Bravo sounds so sophisticated yeah um
I'm in a long just relationship yeah I
saved this one cuz I knew Jack was
coming on I'm like all right I want to
hear Jack what he has to say about this
ok the question is how do we see each
other with the price of airfare um save
yeah I mean if you really want to see
each other I won't really become that
much of a problem you'll make it happen
but I mean Skype is there okay Skype
instant messaging is there it's it's
very easy talk across the world these
days mm-hmm
great advice with Jack yeah instead of
shooting a co-ed kitted it how strong my
relationship Evelyn is a fair point like
if you really wanted to see each other
you'd make it work yeah like you you
were in a long-distance relationship as
well well not that long though but I
yeah it was it was a couple months yeah
I think actually we've all we all have
yeah yeah yeah come on this guy's ready
as well so um yeah if it works it works
what is it suppressing yes sir that's
just what it boils down to really is it
yeah so confused this is most upfront
answer we know thousand for the answer
am buy your own plane and flyer and be a
pimp and bring her out to dinner
whoa we-we-we the wikiHow
how to become becoming everything I'm a
pilot
how do become an eagle some shake ah we
coming up become a rapper so you can
afford your own plane ray william
johnson is really good appreciate this
it's us yeah he has his own plane
doesn't he I don't know why what what I
assume so alright guys that's it this
broken podcast I hope you enjoy it hope
you enjoyed our guest mr. Jack septic
guy beautiful beautiful addition we
can't wait to have him back for the
third time it's gonna happen cuz if
maybe next time as we cuz you guys love
me so much you always want me around
isn't that right guys is that the the
Otto cycle Lucky Charms but I guess
that's that's not even a good joke right
sighs it was better than all of the
others Ken what that's your best joke is
my Jojo Tennant in any way you guys most
you probably know jack but you can check
them out at jacksepticeye others under
everything jacksepticeye just google
that you can see all this stuff the
privileges of having a weird name you
get older yeah fantastic let's play a
funny guy I love us intros and outros so
special we're gonna end band with the
hits out true yeah yeah we got we eat
what we all got do it my outro yeah Jack
lead us lead us in your outro okay you
need a headphone warning
yeah it's go ahead do it okay so I'll do
the outro but you guys have to do that
in the next video thing really really
high-pitched okay I guess wait wait okay
well thank you guys so much watching
this podcast if you liked it punch the
like button in the face like a boss and
my face all round thank you guys and I
will see all your dudes
Wow way to make a good douche kid
attitude